hey guys compare us here altered for our
body and for our de-stem the other thing
I wanted to show you my favorite
shoulder warm-up exercise and of course
there are many different ways of
incorporating your shoulder into
workouts you have this type of playing
static pressing you have potentially
handstand push-ups or inverted crosses
and so on these obviously have lateral
Linea of pressing benchpress military
etc etc goes on on this particular moves
includes to me by Jim Keane Jim thank
you very much very impressive athlete
and CEO and it's effectively an inverted
kettlebell press with rotation now this
exercise can be particularly dangerous
if you lose your grip on the kettlebell
so you should start with dumbbells light
dumbbells work your way up to light
light kettlebells I mean as light as you
can find and slowly over time use chalk
if you can work your way up you don't
have to go for max weight this is not a
strength exercise per se it just gets
all of your stabilizing muscles firing
so here's what it looks like
I had kettlebell I'm going to start with
effectively a swing and then I'm going
to clean it here press up and then I'm
going to rotate I like to do say five to
six to either side and I'll show you
what that means so we're here I get a
nice strong grip I'm going to do swing
up press and then keep lots of nice
tension in my opposite hand and glutes
and so on abs and then I'm just looking
up at it and rotating as far as I can
five or six times to either extreme okay
so this is 16 kilos so 35 pounds it's
going to be too heavy for a lot of
people was too heavy for me in the
beginning certainly this is a very
neurologically intensive move and grip
intensive moves to start flight let's do
the same thing on the other side so
again this is my weaker side potential
to reconstructive surgery here
yeah the swing okay boom up nice grip
slow press up and then rotate
and then literally that's it
I don't do six sets I don't do 20 reps I
do six to either side with each arm and
that's it
have you heard a five bullet Friday well
if you haven't that's good news I'm
excited because it is my most exclusive
content it is free and you can check it
out right here
lots of actionable tactics tools and
more